what made you decide that now was the
time for quirky Sinclair to come back I
don't know if that was the main thing in
the movie that I was thinking about so
I'm glad you enjoyed it it was a whim
shall we say ok yeah were you initially
going to have an another role or when
you know my other role was to be not in
the movie oh no yeah well no I you know
I thank you but it was just a little
idea and then I did it yeah you know we
were talking before we came out and you
said that a question that you're often
asked by people that's not your favorite
question and I understand why is oh I
love that character you played where is
he now and your answer as well it's a
fictional character so who really knows
but I get that all the time which is odd
it that people don't understand it you
know I don't know if people come up to
the act of the plate been her and say so
what's he doing well he's not he's not
doing anything cuz he's if he was alive
he'd be dead because he would be 2,000
years old so he's but he's not he was
never was real so but i keep getting it
i hope maybe someone after the show can
but my understanding is that for all of
you you do come up with intensive
backstories for the characters you're
playing now so i would say well there's
not a we really a we in that this is uh
actually i mean certainly it's not we
but you you and your cast members no no
no no no this is actually a writing
thing we're in this case Jim Piddock and
I spend six months writing the backstory
for all the actors all the parts it's
the same way when I work with Eugene
Levy we write the back histories for all
the characters as well as the story
obviously is where and what happens in
all the scenes so do you have a list of
nope
and I don't have any lists in your in
your mind have no I have a list of
guitars that I've collected Oh which I
which I have at home oh excuse me I just
flew in from London not tonight but
recently enough that I'm still but what
was the list you were talking is there
because that's why we're here and is do
you have a non-literal list yes of
potential film ideas that no don't make
the cut now I don't now I'm not being
facetious no there's no list there's
nothing no I I finish a project this
took me two years to do and then I tend
to meander around a bit I I do a lot of
music in between between my last film i
did to music tours to record albums some
other stuff and then maybe something
pops in my head or maybe it doesn't and
was there a germ of the mascot idea was
there something or has it been
percolating for a while or did you see
something that made you think I've hit
it well I think I think their germs
involved like oh you mean be specific I
see yes well there are things that you
see in your life and my son was a mascot
oh okay see now we're getting somewhere
this is like a TSA thing down theater
and then you get to get on my son was a
mascot as for a football team eight-man
football team which is not enough it
turns out and he stood in this thing in
the fan that's in the head of this bird
broke the first day so he just was was
hot and i'm not sure why he wanted to do
that in the first place hey I was drawn
to this idea that why would people who
are ostensibly interested in
entertaining or performing in front of
crowds but they're do that without being
seen but given the occasional narcissism
we see with actors
it's a curious thing that you're
anonymous and you're standing in front
of people and you're performing to
various degrees and then you go home and
who was that don't know just a guy or a
woman just as anything so after the last
few films which were I think Warner
Brothers and Sony classics how did you
connect with netflix for this one did
they approach you or well I'd met with
them I did a serious coal family tree
for HBO about three years ago three
years ago and i met with two people I'd
met with HBO and with Netflix and I had
a very nice meeting at that time and
Netflix said we would like to do this
and I decided at that time to go with
HBO and I remembered the meeting and I
didn't go to anyone else I had one
meeting I went to Netflix and I said I
never even met with a film studio and
they said great let's just do this and
the way I work is a bit it's not a
conventional situation there's not a
screenplay there's an outline and and
there you go so they said sure let's go
so you mentioned family tree which is
the series you worked on for HBO and two
of the people who were in that of course
as you all know if you watch the show
was Chris O'Dowd and Tom Bennett right
Sid the Hedgehog at what point working
with them on that show did you think
these are guys I want to have in my next
movie well I can say this about all the
actors have worked with because these
films are different in the sense that
they're they're improvised which you do
which you don't have very often actually
improvised based on this work we've done
to establish who the characters are and
what happens in every scene I tend to
work with the same people because
they're great at it Jane Lynch and you
know people I've worked with and chris
o'dowd was amazing and family tree which
was also improvised and Tom Bennett as
well so I thought of them quite quickly
given that we want to have people from
other places other than the united
states represented in the film and then
you also i love sarah baker who people i
think she got her a really big break on
Louis CK's showed she had well yes she's
a lovely actress in Zach woods to the
woods on Susan yay glee is a new actress
um I got to meet and work with and yeah
some great people how do you scope new
people out are you constantly trying to
find new series on TV are you asking
people to send you reels and or how do
you like to find new people i would say
none of those things I it's a curious
thing because when I do finally get the
name of someone I that someone thinks I
should see there's no there's no script
to read there's no audition per se
because there I talked to them for about
half an hour David Rubin who's worked
with me for many years that his casting
director is very smart and has a great
knowledge of a lot of areas of actors as
opposed to people who were necessarily
improvisers and I trust him and people
come in and i chat with them and then I
based on that conversation we go and we
really go because once they've I've
described them what happens in every
scene and who the characters are there's
no rehearsal when we shoot so we start
to roll we say I say action which
everyone knows means now I'm supposed to
talk theoretically or not talk depending
on that and it's a curious talent you
know talk or not talk you were making me
very happy i'm having like Jennifer
Coolidge flashbacks this is great do you
did you hire a choreographer for
especially for the state Parker Posey
with the armadillo stuff which was so
genius do you have your actors just kind
of go out there do your own thing or I
would imagine some of this was quelle in
the same regard that it's not people
just coming to a set and making stuff up
it's very I've used this analogy
probably too many times but in music and
I've written a lot of music for the
films that I've done if especially in
jazz and other more modern music when
you
improvise it's based on a melody
essentially can be and gia can be in
whatever key the musicians know the
melody which is established and then
they go off and can play other things
but you're within a structure you're not
just doing whatever you want you come
back and people solo and this is akin to
that in the sense that this is very
strict and where this goes this as a
beginning middle and end every scene has
a beginning middle and end in the same
sense shooting that [ __ ] the competition
you can't just have people going out
with you know doing a lighting setup for
10 hours and how just do whatever you
want just have fun you know so no the
answer was yes we found a girl very
gifted Ryan Heffington is a incredibly
gifted choreographer and he worked with
Parker Posey Parker worked on her own as
well and establishing that armadillo
piece she did a lot of that work as well
and we had stunt people as well so
there's a tremendous amount of work goes
goes into it how hard is it to edit
these films in your editing room given
the fact that you know I would imagine
there are takes that are wildly
different but there's so much great
stuff that you're finding and making it
seamless is that a challenge well it's a
challenge it's always challenge we had
155 hours of material in this movie and
mainly because at the end we were
shooting five cameras on the competition
I generally have 60 hours anyway to work
with which is a lot and given that you
know what what the story is it's it's
different in this I don't do any editing
while we're shooting and obviously as
you probably all know you're picking
takes in a conventional script where you
say that's that and then you have a
rough cut by the time you're finished
shooting you almost have a rough cut
there's nothing cut and I sit down with
the editor after we finish shooting for
11 months and we start we take notes and
we just go in and do the work you know
does it remain freshly funny to you
after all that time no no it becomes a
different thing and it's true with any
movie that you're cutting I've done
conventional movies as well where you've
seen it so many times and you're looking
at
from a different through a different
lens i suppose and it's uh whoo-hoo in
the cast had the most uncomfortable
mascot costume hmm well you realize that
or maybe you don't that they weren't in
them for the performances well I would
imagine well I'm Bennett with the
unicycle Tom Bennett could have done all
that work really he could have done all
that work himself he's an amazing
physical clown Parker could have done
that as well but given that you have to
do it multiple times and wouldn't have
been as much fun I would say the fist is
probably the most difficult one because
you're the guy the stuntman who was in
there was rollerblading in a huge thing
and that the hole that he was looking
through was about this big and so
unbelievably challenging that he didn't
crash every second yeah amazing to be
hot very hot in there do you one of your
favorite parts of the process of the
movie is to play the guitar on the on
the soundtrack is that something you
look forward to well this this I only
did a couple of things and normally I
I've written a lot of the music and
played the music and I didn't done this
one but it is one of the more fun things
and I hope my next one will be a music
centric piece actually yeah and you
played with Chris think it's is it dial
feeling feel from nickel creek isla
christie Lee played mandolin on this
track and he's now doing a prairie home
companion he's now the host and he's one
of the great mandolin players in the
world and I asked him to do this and he
he didn't I love it well on behalf of
everyone else in this room I want to say
don't wait ten years before you do
another one we want another one sooner
but Christopher Guest thank you so much
for being here thank you have a great
night thanks thank you everybody for
this see you next time
you